team at aria is loading their piping
bags with black and silver icing as they
construct the raiders theme display
jillian lopez got a behind the scenes
look at all the creations
[Music]
raider nation just got a little sweeter
the pastry team at arya has been hard at
work preparing raider themed desserts to
put on display we've been working on and
up kind of on all these different little
components for about two months our team
has been working meticulously getting
all the details right and the details
are definitely a touchdown so at aria
patisserie we're gonna have two of our
life-size football players here we have
derek carr he's over six feet tall he's
made out of chocolate and fondant we're
also going to have multiple cakes taller
than myself
we're going to have lots of sugar
components we're going to have even a
miniature legion stadium the team at
arya wanted to do something big to
celebrate the raiders it's very exciting
that we finally get our own football
team which is why we wanted to do
something to commemorate such a big
moment and we're really excited to be
part of the raider nation from chocolate
to fondant to sugar pulling the team is
bringing every element of raider stadium
to life including the al davis memorial
torch it's made out of chocolate and
inside we're going to put our sugar
flames which we just kind of worked on
outside so it's going to look just like
the one inside a leaf and stadium so the
flames will actually be attached to a
small board in here but the rest is made
out of chocolate so we have over 200
pounds of chocolate being used for our
entire display and all of the magic
happens right here in this room this is
our chocolate room where we do a lot of
our production for the aria patisserie
so we make all of our bon bons we make
all of our chocolate decorations
and of course a lot of our chocolate
sculptures like this one while you may
not be able to take a bite out of these
chocolate creations you can definitely
admire them and show your raider spirit
we are very excited to see it all just
come together we've all been working
very hard on it
so we're very excited just to actually
get it out there and have it ready for
everybody to see and enjoy
so cool i want to see you with 80 pounds
of chocolate made into made with 80
pounds of chocolate oh let's do it i am
ready to go right